♪
>> OF YOU ARE AWARE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS ASKED ME TO FOCUS
ON ISSUES OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION TO THE UNITED STATES.
AS YOU KNOW, WE INHERITED A
TOUGH SITUATION, AND IN FIVE
MONTHS WE’VE MADING PROGRESS,
BUT THERE’S STILL MUCH MORE WORK
TO BE DONE.
PETE: THAT WAS KAMALA HARRIS IN
EL PASO, TEXAS, YESTERDAY MAKING
HER FIRST VISIT AS VICE
PRESIDENT TO THE BORDER.
LET’S BRING IN REPRESENTATIVE
KEVIN McCARTHY TO REACT.
MR. MINORITY IF LEADER, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT’S YOUR MAKE ON THE
LOCATION, THE TIMING AND THE
MESSAGING OF THE VICE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY.
>> WELL, IT SEEM LIKE SHE SPENT
MORE TIME AT THE AIRPORT THAN
SHE SPENT AT THE BORDER.
BUT TO LITERALLY SAY THAT THEY
INHERITED A PROBLEM AND THEY’VE
MADE PROGRESS?
NONE OF THOSE FACTS PLAY OUT.
YOU HAVE A BORDER THAT WAS
SECURE.
YOU HAD A NEW ADMINISTRATION
THAT CHANGED EXECUTIVE ORDERS
AND INVITED PEOPLE TO RUSH THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
NOW IN MAY WE HAD 180,000
ENCOUNTERS.
THAT WAS A 21-YEAR RECORD OF
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
FOR THE LAST THREE MONTHS, IT
HAS INCREASED.
THE TIME THAT THE PRESIDENT
ASKED THE VICE PRESIDENT TO TAKE
ON THIS JOB, HALF A MILLION
ILLEGAL INDIVIDUALS CAME ACROSS
THIS BORDER.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WE WERE
ABLE TO ENCOUNTER.
THINK THERE’S GOING TO BE MORE
THAN A MILLION INDIVIDUALS THAT
GET THROUGH HERE THAT WE DON’T
ENCOUNTER FROM THE MORE THAN 160
COUNTRIES.
AND WHAT’S WORSE, PETE, YOU
WOULD UNDERSTAND THIS, WE ARE
CATCHING PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST FROM YEMEN.
PETE: WELL, IT’S OPEN FOR SOME,
IT’S OPEN FOR ALL.
AND WHY, IF SHE’S IN CHARGE OF
ROOT CAUSES, WHICH IS WHAT SHE
SAID, HOW SHE CHARACTERIZES IT,
WHY GO TO EL PASO E WHERE MOST
OF THE CONTROLSINGS ARE COMING
FROM -- CROSSINGS ARE COMING
FROM MEXICO AS OPPOSED TO
McALLEN?
WAS ANY OF THIS ACTUALLY ABOUT
GETTING TO THE TRUTH OF WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN.
>> WE KNOW WHY SHE DID IT,
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING
IN A FEW DAYS.
SHE CACKLED AND SAID SHE HASN’T
BEEN TO EUROPE EITHER.
I’M WONDERING IF NEXT WEEK IS A
TRIP TO EUROPE.
PETE: YEAH.
>> SHE NEEDS TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUS.
THERE’S SO MANY RAMIFICATIONS.
ONE, THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THIS NATION.
IT’S NEVER RIGHT TO COME HERE
ILLEGALLY.
BUT FENTANYL HAS NOW INCREASED
BY 300%.
THAT’S NOT JUST AFFECTING BORDER
CITIES.
EVERY CITY IN AMERICA NOW HAVING
PEOPLE DIE FROM THE FENTANYL
THAT IS BEING BROUGHT INTO THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE BORDER.
THE CARTELS THAT ARE OVERTAKING
THESE CITIES.
THIS IS A REAL THREAT TO
EVERYONE IN AMERICA.
AND SHE’S NOT TAKING IT SERIOUS.
YOU KNOW BY HER DENYING GOING
THERE, DENYING THE FACTS OF
WHAT’S HAPPENING AND NOT GOING
TO THE PLACE THAT SHE REALLY
SHOULD BE, WHY ONLY GO TO ONE
PLACE ON THE BORDER?
THAT BORDER IS VERY LARGE --
PETE: WHY SPEND AN HOUR OR TWO,
YOU KNOW?
ABSOLUTELY.
SO MANY QUESTIONS.
I’VE GOT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON ONE
ORR TOPIC, MR. MINORITY LEADER.
COVID-19 SHOWED HOW MUCH OF OUR
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY IS
COMPROMISED BY THE CHINESE.
THE NIKE CEO WAS TALKING TO A
SERIES OF INVESTORS, TALKING
ABOUT THE BRAND OF NIKE.
HERE’S -- THIS IS WHAT NIKE’S
CEO, JOHN DONAHUE, SAID JUST
RECENTLY.
WE’RE THE LARGEST SPORT BRAND
THERE, MEANING IN CHINA, AND WE
ARE A BRAND OF CHINA AND FOR
CHINA.
AND THE BIGGEST ASSET WE HAVE IN
CHINA IS CONSUMER EQUITY.
CONSUMERS FEEL A STRONG
CONNECTION TO THE NIKE, JORDAN
BRANDS IN CHINA, IT’S REAL.
LAST TIME I CHECKED, NIKE WAS AN
MORE THAN COMPANY?
>> YEAH.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT.
I WONDER IF GOOGLE WOULD SAY THE
SAME THING.
PETE: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT CHINA HAS
JUST DONE TO THE WORLD, KILLED
MORE THAN 3 MILLION PEOPLE,
KILLED MORE THAN 600,000
AMERICANS.
THE COUNTRY THAT CHINA -- THAT
NIKE WAS CREATED IN.
REMEMBER WHAT -- CHINA IS A
COMMUNIST COUNTRY THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A COMMUNIST
REPRESENTATIVE IN EVERY SINGLE
BUSINESS.
AND REMEMBER WHAT CHINA DOES
TOO.
THEY ALSO HAVE SLAVE LABOR.
DO YOU KNOW I PUT A BILL ON THE
FLOOR RECENTLY THAT SAID IF ANY
COMPANY MANUFACTURES IN CHINA OR
CONTRACTS WITH SOMEBODY
MANUFACTURING IN CHINA THAT USES
SLAVE LABOR, THEY HAVE TO REPORT
TO THE TREASURY.
217, EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT VOTED
NO ON THAT AND DENIED THAT FROM
COMING FORWARD.
WE NEED TO HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
I JUST ROLLED OUT EIGHT PILLARS.
WE NEED TO STOP THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
FIRST OF ALL, WE NEED TO GET ALL
OUR INTEL AND DECLASSIFY IT SO
THE WORLD CAN KNOW WHERE THIS
COVID CAME FROM IN WUHAN.
NEXT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
ACTUALLY CHANGE THE SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY, THE ABILITY FOR
AMERICANS TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND SUE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
BUT WHY WOULD THE WORLD REWARD
CHINA WITH THE WINTER OLYMPICS
COMING UP?
WHY WOULDN’T WE MOVE THAT?
AND I WOULD THINK NIKE, BEING A
SPORTS OUTLET BELIEVING IN THE
ABILITY OF HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE WOULDN’T WANT TO
HOLD THAT IN CHINA.
NOW THAT THEY’RE A COMPANY OF
CHINA, FOR CHINA, I WOULD
QUESTION THEIR ABILITY TO STAND
UP TO THEM.
PETE: YEAH, OF COURSE THEY HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
IT’S JUST AMAZING TO ME THAT THE
ENTIRE POLITICAL PARTY IN THIS
COUNTRY APPEARS TO BE UNWILLING
TO TAKE ON THE SINGLE GREATEST
THREAT TO HUMANITY, WHICH IS THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE AND THEIR
AMBITION.